it's time for roses and rose hey you
guys it's almost Christmas and time for
the new bachelor season in the new year
I'm so excited and I have wine here's
the thing I'd been on an alcohol cleanse
to cleanse myself of toxins ahead of the
holidays so that I could feel empowered
to drink whatever I wanted during the
holidays but that cleanse has been
broken and here we are so we are winding
down on our rewatch of Emily Maynard
season 8 of The Bachelorette
which we've been doing as you know to
get to know Arie ahead of his season a
premiere on January files on a BSA you
know I'm gonna say that was a shameless
plug for ABC of you guys we are on
episode nine and ten because like I told
you guys we're gonna double up in
December so we can finish things up
right and let's get to it
it's time for the fantasy suites who
will Emily sleep with the answers not
Shawn
[Music]
does it want to compromise her morals so
she didn't do it a little early on the
Christmas carols or am i I don't know
it's fun to get festive and being the
spirit of things I don't have a tree at
home or anything like that really
because I'm busy I don't know
I'd like kids like do you want to do it
for anyone but anyway wow this is
getting really personal back to Emily
who does have a kid transition so it's
fantasy suites and first it's Shawn and
he says he is definitely command of
marry that girl and she's like I don't
want to go to the fantasy suite because
I'm a mom
it just doesn't line up with like what I
believe in I know my daughter Rick he's
gonna watch this and so I'm just
choosing not to now she's gonna do this
spoiler alert you guys for all three of
them here's my only question though is
other people on the show I mean the show
always seemingly implies that they did
sleep together but other people have
talked about how like they didn't sleep
with someone in the fantasy suite they
just stayed up all night talking and it
was really valuable off-camera time when
they asked really real questions of
these people so I don't know I guess
maybe Emily was worried about how the
public would perceive it that people
would assume she did hook up with
everybody but I would have taken that
time I've been like let's get real you
know I have a kid what's your deal
because here's another thing this
episode made me realize man was this a
confusing season ending I'm really
grasping now why you know people love
Sean and he became the bachelor and
Emily was so intense with Arie and like
it's just that with each guy they seem
100% in saying things like I'm
definitely going to marry this person
and Emily seems really into all of them
for very different reasons
it's like Sean is perfect and he's
exactly what you should want an
all-american made
faith family values good-looking
football player Texan kind of a guy Arie
is super physically connected to her the
chemistry the kissing bandit
and he's interesting and he's got a
foreign family's like that's exotic in
like re and then there's you know I
don't see the appeal of Jeff Jeff told
me that he loves me the night and that
his family Emily says a few things here
that in hindsight in hindsight stick out
to me I feel like he gets me in a way
that nobody else says you know what
drink every time Emily says something
telling about Jeff who she ends up
picking as we know I feel like even
though I couldn't say anything back but
he could tell just from like my face how
I felt
meaning does she want to say she's in
love with him mmm
and she remembers him from the very
first night as being something special
we got the first impression rose what's
going on there's a helicopter oh and
this was big Emily says that she was at
home with Ricki making Ricky's lunch and
imagining a guy being there and that
Jess popped into her head that's very
telling because if there's been one
thing that's been a big thing about
Emily it's been that she has a daughter
why have some questions I don't ask you
just like details of stuff I just
there's questions Jeff also asks Emily
some big questions back like where would
they live and emily is like oh I'd move
anywhere for you I don't know like a
burger playing I mean like what about
Ricki and uprooting her in school but
everybody anyway and Jeff says I've
never met two people who are more
perfect for each other anything Emily
likes that Jeff asked her questions back
you know so their fantasy suite went
quite well Wow my body's reacting to
having alcohol for the first time in a
while I guess then Emily is all ready to
tell Jeff that she doesn't wander the
fantasy squeeze instead I think I would
be awesome to forgo our individual rooms
and spend some time in a fantasy suite
together anchors up that would be great
but I can probably understand and
respect that your daughter's gonna be
watching this and my family's gonna be
watching this and your family's in the
alternates and Emily's the reactions
really cute she's like I kind of I
wanted to say it I feel a little turned
down now I wanted to turn
but he's kind of turned me down but also
I think she loves that Jeff predictably
said that and knew what she'd want and
was like so respectful so we drank a lot
this was a lot of Jeff doing right
things now on to Ari
the reason we're here the reason we are
he is the reason that we're here you
walk too slow hurry up I'm excited to
see you wonder it was that kind of the
moment where people started running up
to each other on this show because
nowadays you don't see anybody walking
slow when they see someone for the first
time in a while it's they run up and the
girl jumps on the guy and it's a whole
coordinated thing so Arie and Emily may
have invented this framework for saying
hello on The Bachelor
I think I fell in love with Emily on our
first date and my life has completely
changed since I met Emily whoa drink
every time Ari says something major he
says that he is just ready to propose
[Music]
god this finale is gonna be painful
isn't it
even though I know what happens it's
gotta be painful especially because I've
interviewed Arie twice now and so I
really like him and if you want to check
those out they're up at et online.com
shameless you know this wine was sitting
in the fridge with someone else's for
about three days I don't know this is
what I should have dived into my
re-entrants and alcohol with it doesn't
taste great there is lots of kissing
between Emily and Arie Emily says that
she wants to do the overnight with Arie
because she just loves kissing him so
much Wow and that I think is part of the
issue here Emily and Ari's attraction is
so physical she loves kissing him she
says they sometimes stop to kiss to talk
but like really they love kissing and
this woman who doesn't want to do the
fantasy suites doesn't want to do the
overnights because of her morals wants
to because Arie is so amazing Wow cheers
to Ari we're about to see him spread
that amazingness to 29 lucky women and I
think that a lot of
men might have that like built up like
oh I need to be the father figure like
right off the bat and I think first and
foremost you need to be like fun hang
out with and you know either buddy then
Ari says all this great stuff about how
he loves kids and he knows how to become
close with kids because remember he
dated and lived with that girl who had
kids and Emily loves that so then we're
back to being totally fine with Ari this
was a very confusing episode Emily
doesn't seem to have any real
distinguishable problems with one guy to
another guy it's like she has strong
feelings for all of them they're all
totally ready to marry her and I can't
see it like we knew this whole time it
was evident even if we didn't know what
happens that Sean and Arie and Jef would
be there at the end but now I don't know
how when people are watching this live
they distinguished what would happen
from here it's very difficult Oh drink
every time you stressed out don't do
that and that's how people develop
issues don't do that I'm not ready to
say goodbye to the others yet so emily
is says she's falling for everyone she's
crying and she rarely cries a drink for
Emily hmm and then they all make her
these videos
Emily never in a million years did I
think I would develop the feelings that
I've developed for you I don't know why
she just spent time with each of them
Sean's is nice Sarris is nice Jeff's C
was really rehearsed I knew there was
something there that could grow but now
I know that I'm completely in love with
you
like really rehearsed our dates together
have changed my life forever and Ori
talks about the importance of what he
wrapped her in a blanket my huge crush
turned into love when I had that blanket
wrapped around us
underneath the London sky and you know
what if you love someone wrap a blanket
around them what a metaphor Arie was for
five years okay that's what makes it so
hard just caring so much about them and
wanting him to be happy and knowing that
they never did anything wrong with me
Emily even says that she sees a
fairytale ending with each of them what
a thing to say to those three guys as
they're standing there I need more
information on how she made this choice
I really do because if you truly see a
fairytale ending not even just it's
possible that we could make it work but
a fairytale ending with each of them
I need my information how did you choose
what was wrong with Sean I've been
asking this all season and I still don't
feel I have my answer you guys as we
know she sent Sean home what was wrong
with Sean no I don't get it
I don't get it so guys here's the thing
Sean's season of The Bachelor was like
when I got into the franchise that was
it and now I'm really understanding why
Sean has made the bachelor he is like I
was like women had to viewed him as like
God's gift you know my god oh my god
nothing's wrong with Sean Sean told me
that the most important piece of advice
he gave Ari before Ari started his
bachelor and that he's given all
bachelors this was he said don't let
women see you kissing other women and we
know from the promo Arie did not follow
that advice and I told Sean you that he
didn't and Sean thought that was very
funny he said quote what an idiot
they're good but stuff
okay so yeah Shawn was my first season
and you guys I mean this is just making
me think like should I go back and watch
other seasons please let me know in the
comments do you think I should is the
bachelor franchise our Star Wars our
Lord of the Rings there's so much more
to it so much history so many different
family trees and legacies and and
relationships and and just should i if
so let me know which seasons you think
are must cease I don't wanna watch need
duds
anyway episode 10 of Emily Maynard
season The Bachelor guys it was the men
tell all and I'm gonna be honest with
you I'm not gonna talk about it okay
guess I don't
we had Kahlan and Ryan and Doug and
Chris but who really cares Emily saw
Sean they were lovely to each other man
let's go to the finale one more video
it's gonna go up Tuesday December 26th
where we watch Emily Maynard season
finale and the after the final rose
with Arie it's gonna be the perfect
transition to re season premiering
January 1st on ABC what a holiday gift
what a way to start 2018 cheers to re
into the hopes from new beginnings
so again I just talked to Ari guys after
he had filmed his finale and that
interviews up at et online.com
and Aria is just lovely and he told me
that he fell in love with two women two
women
what happened dari find out more in our
interview thank you so much for watching
again please leave me your comments and
thoughts below are you getting excited
for this season I mean I know people
have been calling Ari not Peter but guys
he's having a really good sense of humor
about it he's been like joking about on
social media and after Emily's thoughts
on Ari's kissing I like just excited to
watch him kiss other women like he can
just do that and that would be enough
for me is that weird
[Music]
thank you so much make sure to LIKE ET
on Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube
and watch our final video of roses and
Rose a with Emily Maynard season finale
and after the final rose
Tuesday December 26th thank you and bye